ginette et normands sont à la retraite
pratiquer l'escaladé l'âge d'or ce n'est
pas la norme
entré en jeu 10 12 à 14 ans puis je
m'amuse jazz etc les jeunes taissy pis
si j'ai pas de miroir on m'a rappelé que
je sens un coeur dans ma tête je le les
ponts non je dis ah non tu faire quelque
chose pour les grimpeurs gériatrique
c'est comme sa deuxième maison ça fait
outre pintât je le connais qui
fréquentent le gym ce genre de retraite
modèle un peu risqué dan n'est pas qu'un
poste au musée c'est le mode de vie de
ces deux s'étonne un sexagénaire degrés
puis enchaîna turquie en grèce en france
en espagne en thaïlande occupe aux mecs
et avant lakovic ça nous permet d'être
voyager beaucoup pour faire les plus
belles places au monde d'escaladé
[Musique]
autour d'eux les jeunes créateurs
semblent fascinés par leur discipline et
leur dévouement ses fans de voir
quelqu'un je vieux comme elle me dit
long parce qu'ils savent ça permet de
montrer que nous c'est peut-être qu'un
jour complète fort qu'un certain cela
non seulement une grille mais aussi
présent dans la communauté
à 65 ans ginette et normands ont appris
à doser janet des escalades deux jours
de suite pour garder la forme
on part avec lui on par la récupération
je regarde comparativement à ses jeunes
fils souvent ils vont vers un peu vif
enfin multiplient ça me fait mal je
syndicats
oui j'ai lu mais j'ai triché pour la
baguette un coup faut pas arrêter en
chemin
si au québec qui sont des exceptions qui
confirment la règle non deux grimpeurs
ont constaté que ce n'était pas le cas à
certains coins du monde la nouvelle
angleterre la californie puis la france
j'ai vu des cheveux gris v on est loin
d'être d'après mot tout ces jeunes nous
en savons hymne au moins la moitié qui
vont grimper encore
avec les cheveux gris pionnier de l'
escalade au québec sûrement et pour
encore longtemps
[Rires]
on a plein de projets mais comment
s'habiller ou si jean françois poirier
20 du canada maury